yes hey Jacko thanks for being here I've
been in the Army for three years now and
for the past year I've been thinking
about putting in a packet for Special
Forces selection so I guess I just
wanted to ask you to talk a little bit
about when you join the SEAL Teams and
what did you do to physically and
mentally prepare yourself and and
generally why did you why did you decide
to join man I wanted to do that since I
was a little kid when I heard that this
I heard that the seals was the toughest
training and that's not the necessarily
true thing all the training is hard
there's the Special Forces the the
MARSOC units the Raiders the Air Force
PJ's and CCC is that it it's everyone's
got their awesome Special Operations
units and the training is all hard and
also when I heard that the seals the
toughest training I said okay that's
what I want to do what do you do to get
ready for you know what you got to do to
get ready for it you you know army guess
what you're gonna be humping a rock
you're gonna be doing forced marches
you've got to be able to run you got to
build a nav you got to be able to do
push-ups and pull-ups and dips and rope
climbs and obstacles that's you got to
do you got to train hard you got to
train as hard as you possibly can and
then you have to tell yourself that
you're not gonna quit no matter what
happens no matter what happens you're
not going to quit
no matter what happens because they're
gonna play a little psychological games
on you like like let's say they go all
he's in good shape he's you know we
can't really touch him physically he's
in really good shape so now you know
what they're gonna do they're gonna say
oh you know you failed this academic
test
you're not smart you're not really smart
enough I mean you seem like a good guy
but you're not really smart enough
you're the kind of you're the kind of
person that would get someone killed
you're gonna make a mistake they're
gonna start attacking you
psychologically or if you're
psychologically strong but you're
physically weak they're gonna be like
hey you're the kind of person that won't
be able to carry me out combat we don't
want you there just saying that don't
quit that's it
don't quit go get some
[Applause]